coluche chaplin johnny la joconde autant
de personnages célèbres que thierry
gorins culte dans la tranche des livres
un art créatif qu'il découvre à l'été
2016 par le plus grand des hasards en
faisant une visite à emmaüs où j'ai
découvert les petits hérissons que tout
le monde connaît qui se faisaient et qui
se font dans les écoles aussi bien que
dans les maisons de retraite qui sont
faits à partir d'un petit livre de poche
je suis allé voir des vidéos sur
internet je regardais comment faisaient
et ensuite j'ai vous faire évoluer ma
technique au fur et à mesure à partir
d'une silhouette en noir et blanc le
castelroussin obtient par ordinateur un
jeu de corte qui lui indique ou découper
chaque page au millimètre près ensuite
on reporte chaque ligne de mon tableau
de cotes sur chaque feuille du livre un
art qui nécessite patience et précision
des qualités innées chez ce retraité de
l'armée enfin la dernière étape je vais
tout simplement découpez fermé petite
marque
mon papier pour ensuite replié chaque
petite partie à l'intérieur dans
l'absolu on pourrait le déplier et le
relire il ne manquera aucun morceau de
papier thierry gorée en pratique
essentiellement son art sur de vieux
livres destinés à la poubelle auquel il
redonne une seconde vie chacune de ses
oeuvres est vendu entre 20 et 80 euros
selon le temps consacré de deux heures à
quatre jours pour les motifs les plus
élaborés on peut même aller jusqu'à
faire un portrait totalement
personnalisée en détourant une photo en
informatique
tout à fait on pourrait réaliser votre
portrait dans un livre c'est une chose
qui est tout à fait réalisable une chose
est sûre cet artiste ne vous empêchera
jamais de rêver